for
[Music]
[Applause]
you're I here
stuff it requires final displacement
right okay so the guy that is not
spinally spinal displacing that's not
where you use it okay so we'll do like
he's very
cautious kind of Grappler and he's going
to go for the collar
T it okay so let's first start out
static collar
and you could of course go into your
own uh colar TI but let's do something
else so what I'm going to do here let's
change is I'm going to post on this and
then 10 con around okay and you'll
you'll get off of this thing so I'm
going to post and turn
around and when I pose so he's going to
try to keep this tight so I can't get in
there so I'm going to create distance
post turn around and come on the inside
and come to this bicep side
here again we'll just start static but
keep it kind of tight and you can see I
can't get my arm in there and I don't
want to go for another collar tie where
it's
50/50 so posst as I circle around create
distance and come in for this bicep
this principle here don't knock it off
come in yield and come around this way
kind of open it I'm going to go here
boom very much like you
do same exact
movement and there he
is
post and you'll have the bicep
okay don't try to knock it on go
inside this inside there you got it and
then stay low stay low so you can change
POS okay all right try
[Music]
tight good
don't contest snake around it follow the
in
[Music]
space
okay okay so as you get this bicep tie
as you get the bicep
tie keep your elbow anchored keep your
elbow anchored don't have it open like
this it's very easy you'll just reverse
it now he got it okay so you're keeping
your elbow anle so as he tries to go
around whatever your elbow is able to
control it okay got it so not up here
like this elbow anchor and keep him
close to you that way it's even harder
for him to do it and when you keep him
close it's not that I'm grabbing him but
my elbows anchored and as he moves
whatever I stay close to that I stay
myself close to keep that elbow anchored
okay don't over burn your triceps
here then to that as you're going around
pom thumb grip all the way around and
then turn your head towards him so not
here anymore we want vage we didn't want
I turn my head towards him and so now he
can't face me so easily you see that
then you remember you have to keep your
feet underneath your head okay so not
here like that your feet is underneath
your head okay got it so he pushes down
on my head he's on that foot whereas if
I'm over here going to get me so all
that has to go together
okay let's try
it dri he's going to try to
drive
there good nice
CL I know you want to go for the other
bicep tie but wait okay first on then
find
other find the other
turn turn your head towards him you want
the angle
on and take this angle over get that
foot your
head lower lower
get your eyes up more there you
go eyes up eyes
up push with that right hand and snake
in with the
left snake in
to keep the
inside yep don't push that down it's not
going to happen in
real sake around in EMP space
head head turn your head the other way
turn your head the other
way so watch this head position okay so
watch watch my position when I come
around here see how we're even we're
kind of even we have the same angle of
attack right do you get what I'm saying
like you can go for both leg I for both
your legs so I don't I don't I don't
want that okay so all I have to do is
turn my head this and now I'm at an
angle to you you see that your Center
Line is over here and my center line is
still on your spine you see that then
just anchor everything keep your H head
up the more your head your face is
tilted down the more subject I into your
leverage on the back of my head okay so
my eyes are more up and I'm at an angle
turn turn your head towards me and
you'll feel the difference do you see
over here like that you can see it okay
try Okay so build on that one and so
he's there I don't want to cross my feet
I move around boom get my position and
I'm going to take that other tricep you
see how I take the other tricep okay and
uh let's have him drive at me he'll
drive and I'll take that turn
Okay so he drives at me and in my
go this is K Naga from the bicep side so
we go from the clinch boom he drives at
me
andom we
go I'm here post snake you drive out of
the way in hold the elbow okay all right
here we
go
drive get the hold of the two
biceps get the biceps he
drives
without get the biceps start on the
triceps move to the biceps
t that's
it post and no contestation don't cut
here move till you out here there's the
space I want okay you drive look where I
am you see that you drive I yield I come
inside with this
ed hold the El okay make sure you're
entering on that ex TR
get to the front get to the front on the
so you can lead him through the circle
that you're
[Music]
making enter Y and enter do not
contest y not yield then
enter the
Bice
[Music]
biceps have to
goes watch my first step
back
this step in
you shouldn't feel anything he's driving
ideal don't hold it here don't try to
shove in yield
in okay try
it get the
Bice drive
slower step back enter
enter right
Twi
throw biceps
bicep that means two that means both
arms in English the is plural means more
than one
Yi throw
BS the reason you're losing the
technique is cuz you lost your mind you
see you're in a state of fear so you
can't do this simple thing got it so
it's not so innocent try it again
biceps go slow go slow reduce the
stress for your
mind you did a cross behind
in if we go slow it's not so you take
advantage and change the the energy
pattern right
step
back step back
then step back yeah yeah actually you
step back no that's a shuffle
back step back enter yes it's so
easy you just got to not be afraid then
you won't test he wants to push you take
a step back now he's not pushing you
[Music]
oh
okay so this time he doesn't generate
he's not generating any energy there's
there's no drive here okay so I'll
generate the energy I'll bring him
around I want that foot to get close to
me okay so I'll hook if if his arm's
dead like that I'd come up to here okay
I use the collar tie to make that
fo start work on the first one boom
there's no energy then I move him boom I
want that foot to come forward okay
let's try
it either get two bicep ties or a collar
tie and the one bicep
tie make step
get your two ties one on each side of
the spine
[Music]
don't cross your
feet get the two
ties don't cross your feet
pull that leg forward close to your
other foot close to your front
foot pull it close to your front foot
you can move your body and do that move
your
body yes in a circle not back all right
let's work on that now so I got my ties
okay and so we're going to change levels
here so pose in I have my two thighs
whichever one you're going to use and
then I want that foot to come close to
my front foot but I'm not going to stay
here my whole body is going to drop I'm
going to drop low like this okay and
that dropping on my weight is going to
bring him even closer you see how he got
closer so same first move one I use my
whole body to change level pretty
freaking low now okay and I will let go
of that head control to get to get to
that point so let's bring the low ring
change the levels with the two ties
go don't let go of the ties yet we just
two ties change
[Music]
levels two ties change levels not one
tie
change
levels you you bring you down James not
him down yes Rod's just trying to match
my levels I didn't bring him down
[Music]
get get look over the head and get
lower you need that front his front foot
near your front
foot that's what whole point is move his
front foot near your front foot
Circle bring it closer drop to a
away so
what there you are get you here okay I'm
going to see as close as that foot is I
want it even closer okay so I am going
to watch the difference I'm up here and
I move you
forward it's the
same I'm go slower now okay so I'm
moving the body's moving you see it
moving right step's going out my Center
is dropping and I start to drop look you
see that's going to make the difference
when my Center Dro okay got it okay now
you're
resisting so when when you there was no
forward energy right okay so you're not
coming with me or when you feel me do
that pull you start to resist and I'm
not going to get it but I dropped my
weight you see and I got it okay all
right try
it you got to shuffle back not just
turn that's better get lower get your
head lower than get your head lower than
his head
get your get your head lower than his
head
again your head should be lower than
their
head near your front
leg keep your eyes up
so your front leg was your right leg
that his left leg should be closer
you got it I don't feel any energy so I
Dr and my head is low okay this arm here
let's this arm I'm going to pick up over
me you see how doing that so I'm here
especially when you drop they're going
to resist right he's going to try to go
up so when he goes up I pop it over me
okay and if my foot wasn't near I'm
going to put it near it's going to be
let's do it in stages we'll start from
here foot
close pop
over drop your
knee to the side circle
around all the way you see around feet
in the line head up not head down push
my head down
okay all the way around past what I want
all the way past what I want good
posture up here pressing in we'll do in
stages again we already got there if I
wasn't there I might have to go heel toe
knee popping around come around this way
get this
[Music]
alignment around this way get that
alignment okay all
right head
up
knee all the way around head up
[Music]
in the
middle don't pick anything up yet just
get to the foot alignment pop it over
pop it
over the order is V to Lo I'm sorry heel
toe knee if you need it otherwise it's
probably just knee if we did it just
right sheo right into
it I want you to use the front leg
on pull the front leg what's your front
leg trist your right leg Yeah okay so
make his left leg come towards your
right leg and the circle drop your
weight there it is pop it over knee good
get your alignment get your head up into
his chest that's
it that's
all if you think about it too much it
gets all weird you're just here the knee
goes pivot on the KN okay try it again
head
up knee knee front knee why don't you
learn one side first do the right
side
KN good pay attention the foot alignment
his two feet and your left
foot head up throw that thing over your
head you're very
weak
push I'm like this and I make I'm going
to be ready to make him move
so this knee has to be right
right near it okay then you have your
posture just like your foot your head
and foot remember when we're standing
it's knee and head right now keep your
eyes up
okay eyes up
you guys move to the
middle it
over
try boom pop it now just pull it like
the back the
back change levels bring that leg to me
you see how I'm low already and it goes
this
way
around there's my
alignment my that's where
we grab the back of
B yes and it just needs to go over your
head you don't don't swing it up a
million miles over your get that arm top
over your head get your head next to his
[Music]
body what you can do remember how like
when you guys first learn clo
guard and you guys would lay
there right like 15th century virgins on
PR remember that and you had to learn
how to not go dead it's the same thing
so as he's as he's trying these mov okay
he go go
I I try to keep the energy alive that
he's
going you got it you understand when
he's pulling pushing pulling I give him
the counter energy like a person not oh
you got me okay try it
[Music]
again you need to get low
on and you can do it from the top now
you can stay slow if you want okay so
he's got his collor tie sorry okay post
I come around no
energy I'm lowering popping it up moving
in the knee hand goes on top goes on top
okay don't put the other hand on top you
just lift the forearm up then out so
this way he lifts let's turn the
camera this way he lifts my left hand he
just pulling into the grip he lifts my
right hand it's going into his leg okay
got it guys got it okay so just like we
did the other day don't try to pick this
up tilt him tilt him off of the leg the
leg starts to get light if your leg was
way out here you're fine you bring it in
you tilt and then you stand up okay if
you put it all
together and you're here Bo and you come
around and this leg gets close you can
do it right away but you're not you
don't want to pick the leg up you want
to displ him the leg gets SL okay let's
try it
try to push more with your head use your
head
more that's
it two on
one your head needs to be lower right
and so that would be the part where you
don't lay there okay stay a little more
active you
okay that's the
same
there like this go like
this okay so I start out on the front
as I start to do the the rest of the
movement this has to come around and
then it can lift
okay use your head your head close
change your levels when you do that then
your knees
closer two on one top hand is on top
just go Palm the Palm it's good
enough push don't lift the leg
up slow down so you can do the right
form you got to pass that arm more nope
change hands that way push with your leg
push then you walk forward that's the
end of the
Drone transfer to the tricep when you're
going to pass that arm from the bicep
side you got to get lower than him
use your head to push him
off keep detail
[Music]
use your head to dry don't pick it up
you're not going to pick my leg up I
guarantee
you you got to go to the tricep much
better on the on the leg you got to go
to the tricep so you can pass it start
on the
bicep
bicep pass that's it good much
better okay
doing the whole sequence no energy move
it drve
in top drrive if you need to bring your
leg in drve leg comes up okay leg comes
up push him to keep his balance going
just like the single leg last time but
this time I'm going push him and let his
leg come this way so I'm not going this
way I'm pushing him the leg comes that
way you guys see that okay so you catch
it around here you're driving there's
the leg and now you have it here like we
did last time grab his head bring it
towards his knee take him in a circle if
you need it usually so I can do this can
get
it if you need to you can always just a
little tap on that leg and it works okay
let's try it okay all
right bup bump bump them bump
him pull his head to his knee Circle to
your right CLE your body to the
right use your body okay not your arms
head to his knee Circle to your right
like that stay in the middle
[Music]
please head to the knee Circle to your
right so
drive
drive see catch it go back in
grab this technique we do all the time
put your leg this this
technique all the time cross this right
here okay so over
here got it here we go and I move
around okay
try pass it good drive with your
head pop it so you got to keep moving
this way go back on his knee with your
right there let's move you in the middle
come up come okay here we are then drive
him drive him that way catch the
ankle there it is got it okay so you
when you catch it yes pull the head then
Circle for the
Thro that's it and if you need to talk
to control the other side of the it
doesn't take you don't need to kick it
out you just need to stop it from being
back underneath his line of gravity you
got it okay
try
try good it pull it first pull the head
first that way he's not going to punch
you too not going to jump kick with his
other leg you got it check his height
good
yep right your uh your right hand oh
you're fine you're on the other
side
EAS
off head Circle
good try to stay in that middle
Place do it
again
good get your arm under try to
relax hold the leg on
leg
Dr your
leg there he is
so all yes okay nice and slow and don't
let the leg the bot
C stay up with it right you understand
you don't want to be p with it okay
[Music]
come underneath with your bicep come
underneath with your leg with your arm
sheriff with your arm
his his leg
is and if I po this
over his leg closer you see that you
want some energy going forward okay so
try it
again po it over slow don't cross your
feet don't get pulled by
that okay never he
falls that you don't want to feel him
okay try it again
[Music]
good two more
each head up eyes up
good
nice good control